nouveaux supports nouveaux outils
nouveaux pigments pictural porte un coup
de projecteur sur la manière dont nos
artistes renouvelle et questionne l'acte
de peindre chacune des salles à son
ambiance ici plus particulièrement nous
voyons des artistes qui font appel à de
nouveaux supports à de nouveaux outils à
de nouvelles techniques à une nouvelle
relation à l'espace sur son échafaudage
baroque louise amara joue exploite aussi
bien le bois que la toile où la
photographie son oeuvre monumentale
évoque la métamorphose de l'art elle
nous raconte l'histoire d'une peinture
qui ces fonds qui tombent du mur pour se
développer au sol et en même temps avec
l'échelle qui peut aussi remonter au mur
donc c'est un espèce de flux permanent
d'imagés de forme qui ce qui se répète
sur deux toiles de 4 mètres sur 2
jacqueline fabien choisi de décrire le
déclin de la commune de basse-pointe
gelé connu autrement avec cinémas
restaurants magasins mouvement et
aujourd'hui voilà j'ai été surprise par
cette vision je laisse beaucoup la
peinture évoluer par elle même c'est à
dire qu'il ya des coulures qui a des
flaques des éclaboussures le jardin
d'éden de luz severino se veut à
plaidoyer pour la protection de la
nature la plus martiniquaise des
peintres dominicaine multiplie les
gestes inattendus
la technique est basée sur l'association
des différents supports
la chute à la peinture décollage de mes
propres aux ordres et que je démens
avant de les revendre sur toile et
concernant ce type d'installation
peut-on réellement parler de peinture
la peinture s'enrichit au fur et à
mesure de toutes formes artistiques de
techniques inédites ce qui émerge est
donc ce sont ici
il cite ici une oeuvre qui est à la fois
peintures installations sculptures qui
est souple recto verso à laitages de
jeunes peintres parfois issus du street
art côtoient des ténors comme raymond
mes délices la fondation a déniché deux
oeuvres datant de plus de 20 ans dans un
recoin de l'atelier de l'artiste
ils ont bien vieillir veut dire s'ils
pensent qu'elles sont restées en
d'actualité parce que c'est vrai qu'il
ya une technique tout à fait
particulière pour les réaliser toutes
ces oeuvres sont réalisées au couteau à
la chronique donc avec dépeignent des
outils que j'aime que je réalise
moi-même pictural 35 signatures plus de
70 oeuvres mises en valeur jusqu'au 19
juin à la fondation clément